by the way we got to get to what the
florida segment we used to do guy saves
puppy from monster alligator while
smoking a cigar we got to just end it on
this story
because i mean this is some florida [ __ ]
right here i'm sure you guys have seen
this but i mean let's break this down
here you go
this has to be florida if it's not
florida then it's still florida
king charles spaniel and rests it from
the jaws of the alligator
it takes several seconds
oh my god the puppy didn't suffer a
puncture
to its belly but it's doing just fine oh
my god dude
the one thing they cut off how do you
get your fingers out at the end
yeah what did he do i mean i don't he he
might just be so old school
that he got a finger bitten off and
didn't even mention it right
yeah that is that hardcore because have
you ever been bit by a puppy
it it well yeah it doesn't hurt right
does it no it does they have the
sharpest little [ __ ] teeth
similar to like a tiny alligator a baby
alligator like that
dude they could lap your finger off
clean do you think there's
any chance in hell that that guy voted
for joe biden
you imagine yeah they interview him
after and he's like so i just saw my
little puppy in there and i just had to
save him
yeah he's like i'm just hoping he's like
what are you hoping for it for chris
he's like i'm just hoping for a smooth
transition to the president
um all right bubbas here we go uh this
is our that was our pseudo penis moment
our ppm
cause he was he was a bear i mean you do
great filling in for yanni
yoni has covered he's gonna be fine
we'll be back next week where can people
find you mike you see
uh at i am mike cannon social media my
canon comedy youtube and we
i also have a patreon with mike feeney
uh the the
emaciated man of comedy and brendan
sagalo called uh what's the scenario
it's patreon.com
scenariopod
[Music]
good morning
[Music]